playán pinker un paciente de diálisis de
82 años fue el primer receptor de la
vacuna británica contra el cob y 19
bueno la vacuna significa todo para mí
para mí es la única manera de volver a
la vida normal este virus es terrible
reino unido es el primer país del mundo
en usar el fármaco desarrollado por la
dupla de astrazéneca y la universidad de
oxford el país fue también uno de los
pioneros en usar la inyección de fisher
y bryant tech la vacuna oxford
astrazéneca trae nuevas esperanzas dado
que es menos costosa y es más fácil de
almacenar las autoridades ya han pedido
más de 100 millones de dosis la mitad ya
están disponibles
creo que este es un momento realmente
crítico estamos en el punto de ser
abrumados por esta enfermedad así que
nos da algo de esperanza pero tenemos
algunas semanas difíciles por delante
exagero sin embargo la situación
sanitaria en la isla es cada vez más
crítica con más de 50 mil contagios
diarios durante varias jornadas una
situación que preocupa particularmente
en escocia donde la ministra principal
anunció un nuevo confinamiento mijares
haití tenemos
introducir a partir de la medianoche de
esta noche durante el mes de enero un
requisito legal para permanecer en casa
excepto para fines esenciales esto es
similar al cierre de marzo del año
pasado marchó a ser los científicos
británicos han expresado también
desconfianza sobre si las inyecciones
funcionan contra la nueva variante del
virus hallada en sudáfrica por su parte
el primer ministro británico boris
johnson adelantó que el país podría
enfrentar nuevas y más estrictas
restricciones